it's not every day a prime minister
feels relieved to step into a crisis
that has the potential of developing
into war
but that may well be the way boris
johnson feels arriving here in cave away
from the party gate scandal hoping to
deflect attention at home
here the prime minister is facing what
he called a grim reality
but he's a welcome friend coming with
new funding some
118 million dollars to fight corruption
alongside other countries we are also
preparing
a package of sanctions
and other measures
to be enacted the moment the first
russian toe cap
crosses further into ukrainian territory
the uk has so far trained more than 22
000 ukrainian soldiers and donated more
than 2.5 million dollars in defense aid
these are days of frantic diplomacy it
feels like kev has become the center of
europe there's not one day that goes by
without a high level visit money and
weaponry are also pouring in
but there's one crucial point that is
still lacking
and that is a united front among nato
members
this image could only worry ukraine
hungary's prime minister victor orban at
the kremlin meeting russian president
vladimir putin
the visit was about signing an energy
deal but the ukraine crisis took center
stage there too
orban has ruled out any nato deployment
to his country
around the same time in kiev president
zielinski was meeting with the polish
prime minister gas was also on the
agenda here finding ways for ukraine to
rely less on russia when it comes to
energy supplies
the ukrainian president would have also
urged his visitors to tone down the
rhetoric feeling that the already
fragile economy could go in a tailspin
his message to ukrainians
this is not the time to panic yet and
the country is well prepared
the government has issued a map with
more than 5 000 shelters around kiev the
main ones being the soviet-built subway
stations for now life goes on as usual
i feel people are worried in words but
not in action if you're talking about
people leaving the city or stocking up
on food or looking for bomb shelters i
don't think that's happening i don't
know anyone who's thinking like that
what she like world leaders also doesn't
know
is how all this will end up
this is not only about the sovereignty
of ukraine or its right to one day
become part of nato
it's also about drawing new lines east
and west competing over the new security
architecture of europe
ukrainians hope they won't be left out
in the cold
abdul hamid al jazeera kiev